donc les leçons de notre baromètre de
janvier le président serait-il agacé par
la popularité de son ancien premier
ministre flora sauvage
mauvaise passe pour l'exécutif pour la
première fois depuis cet été le chef de
l'état arrive sous la barre symbolique
des 40 % d'opinions favorables
il est en recul de 5 points à moins de
100 jours de la présidentielle il est
même dépassé par son ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe qui est jugé
plus compétents plus convaincant et plus
proche des gens ainsi pour deux tiers
des français edouard philippe serait un
meilleur président de la république je
me félicite cahors philippe soit la
personnalité politique préférée france
et quand vous le savez la partie
favorisant son bar des politiques et par
conséquent je pense que c'est tout à
fait mérité par la façon dont il a
gouverné par le personnage lui même au
sein du parti présidentiel
on relativise toutefois cette percée ça
n'a aucun sens parce que on compare
quelqu'un qui a été premier ministre et
était un excellent point miss vous avez
compris que mon soutien a toujours été
pleins et entiers avec un président en
exercice
voyez les lé baromètre des personnalités
politiques telles questions à mesure
aujourd'hui celles qui sont généralement
plus haut celles qui sont complètement
retiré de la vie politique pourtant les
français en sont persuadés deux tiers
d'entre eux pensent qu edouard philippe
va revenir sur le devant de la scène
politique le baromètre au dos que ça
pour masquer la république sénat lcp et
20 titres de la pqr les tendances voilà
ce qui nous intéresse mois après mois et
j'accueille gaël sliman bonsoir vous
retrouvez vous êtes président
cofondateur doxa bérengère bonté bonsoir
mais en gère bienvenue journaliste
auteur de le sioux les faces cachées
d'edouard philippe on va beaucoup parler
d'edouard philippe dans ce débat c'est
aux éditions de l'archipel giada bonsoir
vous êtes essayiste auteur de retrouver
la république publié au cherche midi on
est également en duplex avec benjamin
grange qui est président de la société
mascaret bonsoir vous accueillir pour la
première fois bonsoir sens public vous
analyser l'impact des candidats sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les médias sociaux
et puis évidemment les ti siècle pas à
mes côtés comme pauline et mardi comme
tous les jeudis bonsoir laetitia culpa
éditorialiste politique bon gaël le
premier enseignement c'est
ce décrochage des manuels macron oui
c'est un décrochage qui est qui est
important il perd cinq points ça a été
dit dans votre sujet il retombe à 39% de
jugements positifs on a désormais plus
de six français sur dix qui disent non
emmanuel macron n'est pas un bon
président de la république il était
abonné depuis ses 9 derniers mois à des
résultats qui le rapprochait de l'étiage
des 50 50 un petit peu en dessous à 44
45 % de popularité ce qui en faisait ce
que je disais encore le mois dernier un
président extrêmement bien placé
extrêmement mieux placé que tous ses
prédécesseurs dans la perspective de son
éventuelle réélection alors 39% de
jugements positifs ça reste préférable
par est mieux que ce que faisait nicolas
sarkozy un petit peu mieux ça reste
beaucoup mieux que ce que faisait
françois hollande appareils échéance de
l'élection mais c'est un signal est un
signal qu'on a vu dans d'autres enquêtes
avec une une dégringolade qui a suivi
ses propos notamment sur les
non-vaccinés qu'il
dit souhaiter emmerder j'aimerais bien
et emmerder les non-vaccinés davantage
et ça ça n'a pas plu du tout on avait vu
dans les enquêtes que nous avions
réalisé que sur le fond en fait la
grande majorité des français alors
plutôt d'accord pour qu'on fasse ce
genre de choses mais ils n'ont pas envie
comme un président de la république le
nomme comme cela lui dont six comme cela
m'est vraiment un avant après quoi il ya
un avant après le mois dernier on avait
44 % de popularité on l'avait encore
quand on a fait un sondage juste avant
ses propos sur les non vaccinés mais
dans la foulée de ses propos tenus au
parisien eh bien on a vu une bascule
ça vient réactiver trop de petites
phrases trop de ce qu'on a pu appeler
ici ou là des macros nahd sur le fait de
ta qu'à traverser la rue pour trouver du
travail par exemple et tout ça tombe
assez mal pour lui
dans une dans une situation où il va
commencer à faire sentir qu'il rentre en
campagne effectivement et justement
bérengère bonté ce que ce décrochage peu
accéléré éventuellement l'entrée en
campagne du président de la république
je suis pas certaine que temps que tant
qu mikron ce sera à ce point dans
l'actualité on n'a de cesse de dire
qu'on s'approche de la sortie mais c'est
toujours pas le cas je suis pas certaine
que qu'ils aient intérêt à
se révéler maintenant c'est vrai que le
syndrome de l'emmerdeur a merdé commence
à être problématique
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant on
avait tellement souligné que finalement
et notamment les électeurs les
sympathisants à l'air em étaient
d'accord sur le fond tous et non
vaccinés il y en a marre et c'est la
forme la plus lentement mais mais plus
sûrement manifestement fait son oeuvre
et donc il y à il ya quand même
effectivement un honda on ne doit pas on
n'a pas faire la fête quand on reçoit ce
genre d'étude à l'elysée mais est-ce que
c'est pas plutôt mois la réflexion je me
suis fait est-ce que c'est pas plus
alors c'est concomitants il ya cette
phrase emmanuel macron et puis assez
vite après il ya quand même le pataquès
2 du protocole sanitaire à l'école est
ce que c'est c'est pas ça finalement
qu'à accélérer le décrochage de macron
yahia il ya un ensemble et ça aussi
évidemment le tout la tout tout ce qui
s'est passé autour de jean michel
blanquer requis était un des ministres
populaire et très soutenus par la macro
ni donc c'est sûr que ça pour le coup a
probablement aussi fait quelques
quelques dégâts c'est assez paradoxal
parce que cette crise sanitaire le met
en position emmanuel maquet jusqu'à
présent savoir que j'ai de plus tôt le
protéger mais c'est sûr que dès cette
rentrée assez catastrophique écoutez ci
dessous quand on regarde un peu le
détail de ce résultat il ya des certains
chiffres qui vous ont interpellé plus
que d'autres lesquels oui parce que en
effet quand on voit la popularité d
emmanuel macron chez les différents
sympathisants moi j'ai été très marquée
de voir que 40% des électeurs ps 42 %
des électeurs aient l'air et 47% des
électeurs électeurs et sympathisants
d'europe écologie les verts avaient une
bonne opinion de lui est effectivement
tout tant mieux pour lui entre
guillemets je crois que ça démontre
finalement que le président et les
différents gouvernements ont réussi à
réaliser ce que même appel le fameux en
même temps c'est à dire une politique de
gauche et une politique de droite mais
j'ai été surtout marquée par les 47 % de
sympathisants europe ecologie les verts
alors qu'on dit matin midi et soir que
c'est le président anti climat que c'est
le président anti écolo c'est tout du
moins ce
qu'a fait exactement mais je crois que
finalement ça va dans le sens de montrer
qu'il ya eu des réformes très social le
100% santé la pma pour tout le congé
paternité des réformes de droite je
crois que valérie pécresse présenté
aujourd'hui son programme sécurité il ya
eu dix mille policiers en plus la police
de sécurité du quotidien et puis sur
l'environnement sur l'écologie une
position qui est beaucoup moins
dogmatique et qui va dans le sens d'une
envie d'une dune et d'une écologie
pragmatique et je crois que ça
finalement ces traits marquants sur la
baisse de popularité moi je crois
simplement que le président il est en
train de faire sa mue de président à
candidats et forcément quand on est
candidat on est clivant parce qu'on
descend dans l'arène et finalement c'est
ce qu'on essaie il avait intérêt et il a
intérêt à être le plus longtemps
possible en posture de chef de l'état de
chef des armées de chef de protection de
la santé des françaises et des français
mais je crois que cette interview dans
le parisien a enclenché la bascule et
donc forcément on est plus clivants
quand on descend dans l'arène alors je
ne lis pas avec une forme d'inquiétude
en tout cas à sa place ça me semble
normal que quand la campagne commence le
président il est entre guillemets si
vous passez l'expression a porté deux
coups de tous ses adversaires et donc
finalement c'est normal qu'ils baissent
un petit peu malgré tout dans toutes les
autres enquêtes d'opinion il est en tête
alors bien sûr ce sont des enquêtes
d'opinion il est en tête du premier tour
et avec une certaine avance voilà ça
montre qui fait sa mue et que finalement
c'est le jeu démocratique qui va
commencer benjamin grange comment
comment on parle on se place emmanuel
macron dents sur les réseaux sociaux et
médias sociaux
alors autant le mois dernier on pouvait
dire que c'était eric zemmour qui
trustaient la majeure partie des
conversations sur internet autant ce
mois ci c'est effectivement emmanuel un
patron qui reprend le dessus mais de
manière très large parce que il est
presque 45% plus haut que
emmanuel que eric zemmour est en fait il
ya plusieurs phénomènes qui explique ça
le premier c'est c'est d'abord le
tassement d'eric zemmour c'est vrai que
le fonds de commerce d'eric zemmour a
été quand même beaucoup toute une
histoire de polémique est hélas ce dans
les 30 derniers jours c'est plutôt
finalement les transfuges qui ont fait
parler d'eric zemmour et donc ça fait
moins parler sur les réseaux et puis on
a l'effet retour du coc vide qui a fait
un finalement à l'eau et qu'ils
profitent finalement en premier lieu au
chef de l'état alors ça c'est vrai qu'on
te on dit les choses de manière
quantitative mais de manière qualitative
il faut avoir un deuxième niveau d'
analyse parce que on regarde votre
regard des conversations sur le
président on s'aperçoit que elles sont
un tantinet plus négative qu'elle ne
l'était avant et il ya deux choses qui
expliquent st la première est là
évidemment
elle est en rapport avec locaux vides
évidemment les français en ont marre
mais la deuxième est plus intéressante
c'est surtout le fait qu' il ya une
ambiguïté aujourd'hui dans le
candidat-président macron et que cette
ambiguïté elle finit par agacer et les
français disent il faudrait quand même à
un moment que ils sortent de cette
ambiguïté et quand il fait un
déplacement à qu on sache vraiment si
sanaa et placement de président ou un
déplacement candidats à la fois la
quantité puis l'analyse qualitative
je rappelle quand même cet élément
toujours tiré de votre baromètre gaël
65% des français
en proposant aux mères des jeunes
vacciner 65 % des français qui estiment
qu'un président ne devrais pas dire ça
laetitia c'était quoi la stratégie
présidentielle pourquoi il a choisi
d'aller sur ce terrain c'était en tout
cas entêté vous savez en traîne topic
sur twitter c'est à dire celle ce
président ne devrais pas dire ça ça a
vraiment été la phrase qui est ressorti
mais il a explosé twitter le soir même
c'est à dire que tout de suite on a
compris
allez-y non mais ça fait une référence
évidemment au livre consacré à françois
les spectateurs sont férus politique
mais je le rappelle en tout cas
effectivement il avait affolé les
réseaux sociaux et l'elysée n'en était
pas du tout étonné c'est à dire qu'il
savait très bien qu'en faisant sortir
cette interview les faits bon bah allez
être immédiat et donc il n'était pas
étonné étaient plutôt satisfaits et en
fait il a voulu d'après mes sources 1 il
a voulu utiliser ce mot en faisant
référence à leur attention c'est un peu
tiré par les cheveux au général de
gaulle en 65 quand il est en ballotage
dans l'entre-deux-tours voyez or le
général de gaulle pour la première fois
accepte une interview on face à face
avec un journaliste télé voilà c'est la
première fois qu'il accepte et il parle
comme par les français c'est à dire que
le général de gaulle abandonne sa
majesté son geste présidentiel et son
côté jupitérien et parle à la ménagère
alors il dit oui alors c'est tout à fait
normal la ménagère elle a envie du
progrès alors par progrès il entend
aspirateur automobile lave vaisselle et
en même temps la ménagère a besoin que
sa fille ne décroche pas et que le mari
ne fasse pas la bamboche c'est vraiment
les termes du général de gaulle et il a
l'impression comme ça de parler comme
d'être dans la cuisine des français de
leur parler comme tout à chacun ça
fonctionne sa popularité remonte et
finalement il a réussi à descendre donc
jupiter est redescendu parmi les siens
et a convaincu voilà c'est la référence
sauf qu'on est 80 ans plus tard et
qu'emmanuel kron a tous je veux on n'est
pas 80 je me disais en 265 2 il on est
soixante ans plus tard un peu moins un
poisson
40 j'en aurai plus quoi oui 60 ans plus
tard si le procédé est le même en tout
cas la façon de le faire est
complètement différente pourquoi parce
que général de gaulle parle comme les
français mais n'insultent pas les
français le problème c'est bien le terme
emmerder d'ailleurs que c'est de l'art
go on peut dire que tout le monde
finalement peut-être l'utilisent c'était
le mot le plus utilisé par françois
fillon en 2016 et 2017 personne ne l'a
remarqué une archive de valérie pécresse
génial a retrouvé pendant la campagne
primaire et l'air et parle des trafics
de drogue elle dit en mer des trois fa
dans la phrase avec d'autres mots encore
plus grossier bon là on tombe sur
emmanuel ça ne fonctionne pas
visiblement ça ne fonctionne pas parce
qu'un président ne devrais pas dire ça
selon une majorité des français mais on
voit et c'est tout l'enjeu des manuels
macron s'est trouvé ce point décrit
libre entre la verticalité et
l'horizontalité il ne l'a toujours pas
trouvé gail simone c'était pompidou
aussi qu'ils disent à arrêter d'emmerder
les français en coulisses où il était in
c'est pas pareil et surtout je pense au
delà des mots employés que dans dans les
enquêtes qu'on a pu réaliser sur la
crise sanitaire les français nous disent
qu'ils sont prêts axe qu'on fasse
beaucoup d'efforts à ce qu'on leur a
demandé beaucoup d'efforts et sont prêts
à les accepter il souhaite d'ailleurs
que ce soit d'abord les non-vaccinés
qu'il fasse les efforts plutôt que ceux
qui ont fait l'effort de se vacciner
donc sur le fond il ya ce sujet mais il
ya aussi cette idée en même temps que si
ça n'est plus utile si on n'a plus
besoin de passani terre ou de passes
vaccinale tout ça doit s'arrêter dans le
cadre que nous avons publiée dans le
figaro juste dans la foulée des propos
du présent il y avait cinq militaires on
est prêt à accepter encore des efforts
on est prêt à ce que les non vaccinés
ben on leur impose des choses entre nous
parce qu on les emmerde mais at on
besoin de le dire mais en revanche on
n'est pas là pour faire plaisir au
président de la république en plus la
phrase complète c'est j'ai bien envie de
euh j'ai bien en mer en vidant verde et
non vérifiées alors si on veut faire
l'exégèse complète de cette histoire on
sait qu'en fait il rebondissait sur un
propos lectrices du parisien que
peut-être il n'aurait pas employé ce mot
là spontanée alizée mais c'est
intéressant c'est avec pas mal de
recruter sur les rouges ont tiré les
leçons en tendance est sur le flanc de
fournels acquisitions dans notre sondage
et sur le fond les gens disaient sur wii
il faut qu'il le fasse mais il n'a pas
besoin de le dire comme ça et s'agissant
des manuels macron ça fait écho à bien
d'autres propos qui relevait de ce ce
même ce même sujet
voulais rajouter un bon ensuite juste
dans les dents les résultats de votre
enquête aujourd'hui on en parlera
peut-être justement à propos de leurs
philippe médias il ya cette brutalité
oui oui j'ai planté chez emmanuel macron
est beaucoup moins cher chez edouard
philippe et pour le coup on sent
également la tendance est exactement ce
résultat est quelque chose qui doit qui
peuvent découler de cette tout à fait
histoire d'emmerder ça veut dire que
dans les items dans les qualificatifs
négatifs qui
qui se prêtait au président et au
président merci de m'aider il y à cette
brutalité ah oui absolument mais angers
remonte à raison on a fait des
comparaisons on en parlera au fond par
là mais entre entre edouard philippe et
emmanuel macron on a posé des questions
on les teste en duel tous les deux sur
un salon de critères d'image et puis
surtout on a posé toute une batterie de
critères d'image sur edouard philippe
qu'on venait de tester peu de temps
avance sur emmanuel macron les mêmes
items et emmanuel macron sur la
brutalité c'est tout à fait
spectaculaire
59% c'était il ya quelques qu'une
quinzaine de jours en mois de janvier
disait d'emmanuel ma troupe macro oui il
est brutal on est à 23% des français qui
disent oui edouard philippe est brutale
alors que les trois quarts 76% 10 à nos
noms edouard philippe c'est pas
quelqu'un de brutal et sur le côté
sympathique les deux tiers des français
nous disent encore philippe il est
sympathique annuellement 40 % qu'ils
trouvent sympathique il ya vraiment
cette dimension d'un président qui
encore une fois ça vient répéter rappelé
revenu faire faire se remémorer d'autres
phrases qui ont été d'autres propos qui
ont été tenus par le passé par emmanuel
macron est effectivement pas par edouard
philippe alors effectivement la cote
d'adhésion d'edouard philippe il est là
il est à 39% galessi maladresse avec
vous parce que c'est quand même d'abord
une baisse il perd 6 points quand même
oui mais en fait il faut voir d'où il
vient et où il est par rapport aux
autres clair que je rappelle que notre
pas le principe de nos codes des lésions
ses comptes est en gros 25 personnalités
politiques qui sont en activité et donc
on ne teste pas des personnalités qui ne
sont plus du tout en activité et on
demande aux français à chaque fois ci ce
sont des personnalités qui le
soutiennent donc c'est plus une cote
d'adhésion molins est une cote de
popularité molle est-ce qu'ils
soutiennent cette pauvre personnalité
est-ce qu'ils ont de la sympathie pour
elle ou est-ce qu'il la rejette ou
encore ce qui est le plus fréquent est
ce qu'ils sont complètement indifférent
et dans le cas d'edouard philippe on à
39% de soutien et de sympathie total des
deux ça le site eu 6,7 points au dessus
de tous ses poursuivants et surtout il
est numéro un depuis qu'il a quitté
matignon systématiquement sur cet accord
et ça c'est intéressant en partant même
temps ils ne suscitent quasiment pas de
rejet certes il est numéro un en
adhésion et sur la côte de rejet il est
dernier ex-aequo avec roselyne bachelot
et c'est plutôt bien d'être dernier en
côte de rejet contrairement à eric
zemmour qui est numéro 1 de clé un petit
moment qui est toujours premier le max
edouard philippe emmanuel macron c'est
vraiment l'un des enseignements
intéressants du baromètre doxa mascaret
64% contre 33% préférés de leurs
philippe et même écran et à la question
serait-il un meilleur président 61%
pensent qu'il doit philippe serait un
meilleur président qui mêle macron
comment vous l'analysez ce que vous
dites
finalement il est dans l'arène politique
mais pas tout à fait est ce que c'est ça
qui le peut être le sert comment vous le
net la première chose que j'ai pensé
quand j'ai lu les résultats de cette
étude c'est edouard philippe est parti
au bon moment il faut rappeler le
contexte dans lequel il est parti on
verrait des crayonnés de on venait de
descons fine est partie en tout cas aux
yeux des français il a quitté les
responsabilités on venait de descons
fine et les françaises et les français
avaient oublié et moi c'est ça qui m'a
marqué le contexte dans lequel était
edouard philippe avant la pandémie ne
seraient quelques jours c'était le 49-3
à l'assemblée nationale sur les
retraites il venait de passer une
séquence où on avait eu l'âge pivot
toutes ces polémiques sur l'âge des
équilibres dans la réforme des retraites
il avait passé une année difficile avec
des réformes sur la réforme de la sncf
la proposition loi casseurs les samedis
qui se succèdent à l'arc de triomphe
avec des violences absolument inédite et
robin km et les 80 km/heure donc je ne
faire de politique fiction mais je crois
que si on avait posé ces mêmes questions
là à l'époque sans doute que les
françaises et les français auraient
moins choisis edouard philippe ensuite
moi je dis tout le temps c'est comme le
bon vin edouard philippe il a pris entre
guillemets en popularité avec le temps
qui passe loin des responsabilités ça ne
me surprend pas je pense simplement que
en effet le présent de la république
depuis et d'un philippe est parti fin de
la première vague il ya eu cinq vagues
est en fait en regardant cette étude je
me disais mais pauvre pauvre le nouveau
premier ministre jean castex qui était
monsieur déconfinement et qui en fait
est devenu monsieur confinement et
monsieur deuxième troisième quatrième
cinquième vague moi je pense que
simplement c'est un effet psychologique
qui est dû à la pandémie edouard
philippe il était contesté à l'époque
tant mieux qu'ils le kill kill kill et
cette cote de popularité là c'est un
homme d'état il l'a démontré mais
peut-être que c'est moi qui
sous-estiment l'importance de l'étude
mais il n'y a rien qui m'a
fondamentalement choqué si ce n'est
qu'on a tous oublié le contexte d'avant
pandémie ce fameux 49 3 qui pour le coup
est très brutal aux yeux de des
françaises et des français mais alors si
génial rapidement c'est pas faux que
quand on sort des responsabilités ça a
été dit on l'a vu par fellini aussi on a
un boost c'est vrai c'est mécanique mais
il ya quand même un paramètre qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que pendant quasiment
toute la période où il était où on avait
les deux têtes de l'éthique les
présidents des premiers ministres
edouard philippe était préféré à
emmanuel macron ont testé dans notre
baromètre politique comme on le fait
encore avec castex aujourd'hui la
popularité du président du premier
ministre a aujourd'hui on a le président
devant le premier ministre et quand je
dis aujourd'hui ces deux puits de castex
est à matignon quasiment à l'époque où
c'était edouard philippe edouard
philippe plaisait davantage c'est lui
des avantages qu emmanuel macron y
compris vous avez raison quand des
mesures voulues par edouard philippe
était reproché manuellement je pense
beaucoup au gilet jaune ou 80 km
capable bissonnet des jaunes mais ça n'a
pas trop chez un aveu d'échec cuisant 6
à 9 ans a marqué le kanun en oui mais
c'est aussi ça n'a pas été rose
à l'époque déjà ça n'était pas c'est pas
seulement que les gens ont oublié c'est
que même au moment des faits il nie il
ne leur reprocher pas tant que ça à
edouard philippe parce qu'on en revient
aux attributs d'image ils le voient
comme quelqu'un de plus humain plus à l
écoute plus sympathique moins brutale
qu'emmanuel mac je rappelle que vous
avez enquêté un bérengère bonté pour ce
livre bleu sur les faces cachées
d'edouard philippe eux aux éditions de
l'archipel donc c'est vraiment un
travail en profondeur que vous avez
menées il a été plus populaire qui
emmanuel macron pendant toute la durée
de six mois magie j'ai dit à quoi ya un
ou deux mois s'il ya deux mois voilà il
ya deux mois où il y en a un juste au
moment de la décision des 80 km/heure et
un petit un petit coup nous et puis et
puis et puis en fait assez vite ça
construit là aussi son image d'homme
d'état mine de rien parce que cette
histoire de sécurité routière est quand
même quelque chose si on l'avait vu avec
jacques chirac deux de porter et puis il
ya un autre moment effectivement dans le
dans la période de dd gilet jaune où la
ces mais les deux les deux têtes de
l'exécutif descendent mais ce qui est
très frappant effectivement c'est
pendant toute cette période les trois
années il est devant on se souvient de
jean pierre raffarin qui était géré un
premier ministère de paratonnerre pour
faire simple on prend autant normal là
on avait vraiment un phénomène inverse
et il sort avec 15 points d'avancé sur
emmanuel macron à la fin de la pandémie
en juillet début juillet 2000 des 1020
il a quinze points d'avancé et il
regrette que pressé de rêve plus du lot
garder plus longtemps à matignon alors
moi je m'en fait le le sait c'est clair
que l'on l'enquète d'aujourd'hui moi me
conforte encore dans l'idée du look et
demi mon dieu mais quelle erreur quelle
erreur en avoir de l'avoir sorti ça
dépend est alors à la suite quelle
erreur ça dépend parce que le règlement
aujourd'hui aux éditions des deux
teckels ce mois et depuis quelques mois
c'est clair que il profite de ne plus
être aux manettes d'avoir d'être sortie
à un moment où souvenez-vous en juillet
de la première année de cette pandémie
on pensait que la sphère était en train
d'être réglé donc il avait en plus été
réélu war tout allait bien et et la
garder cette cette avance avec alors il
ya d'autres facteurs il ya ce ce côté
sioux que je n'écris long moment cette
espèce de prudence c'est quelqu'un qui
quand même depuis deux ans laisse
quasiment toutes les portes ouvertes
tout le temps ce qui exaspère la macro
n'y ai d'ailleurs mais y compris dans la
dans la candidature pas candidature
jusqu'à séparent finalement il a laissé
planer de doute là et puis même quand
ils prêtent allégeance trois semaines
après il fait une interview à challenges
pour expliquer que non non non non à la
retraite ça va pas se passer comme ça
les musiques de macron cette allégeance
et marque sa différence et la partie des
communes alors il est parti aux yeux on
va écouter écouter douar philippe
c'était le 5 janvier il était sur france
alors il parle des législatives puis
l'appel le prêt dans la public a été
large irsa sa majorité
pour reprendre une formule célèbre des
tontons flingueurs je suis pas venu pour
beurrer la tartine
donc quand on crée un parti politique
c'est pour peser dans le débat public et
c'est pour présenter des candidats
et c'est ce qu'on va faire le président
de la république j'ai compris de
l'interview a bien mentionné qu'il avait
envie et en ligne ça ne m'a pas surpris
je l'avais senti cette envie brio je
m'en réjouis très bien il va être
candidat je pense que quand on est
candidat à sa réélection on doit être
dans une logique de rassemblement et
probablement me d'élargissement
après c'est à lui de déterminer la
structuration qu'il envie de donner à
cet élargissement à ces rassemblements
mais il doit être dans une logique de
rassemblement parce que sinon ça ne
marche pas bérengère bonté fan
officielle et anton hunger c'est pas la
citation x et le sandwich ccc brisson
dit
on n'est pas loin mais justement vous le
connaissez bien moi quand je regarde
c'est cet extrait est quelque chose qui
me saute aux yeux c'est à dire que en
commençant comme çà il prend le lead un
peu dans cette discussion il montre que
c'est un homme qui décide et qui est un
petit peu comme ça qui a le pouvoir quoi
de est un homme d'action un homme de
volonté et finalement il fait rien moi
y'a un truc qui est vraiment qui va pas
avec les loin phillips et il a quelque
chose d'une opportunité il ne veut pas y
aller moi j'ai encore eu des proches des
doigts fini pour aujourd'hui se
présenter à la présidentielle oui enfin
ses proches me disent ah non non non non
il ne bougera pas il ne changera pas son
cap mais c'était loyauté emmanuel maquet
mais depuis quand on a d'une loyauté non
mais attendez voulait être président de
la république un nom mais ya pas de
règles assez des règles tacites second
où il est marqué qu'il faut être loyal
quand on veut être président de la
république je suis un joli
il ne faut pas être loyal mais il faut
donner le sentiment qu'on est passé de
regarder ce café macro avec hollande
alors ça par les puissants même sens et
bérangère est ce que ça pouvait être son
moment
de mon point de vue non pas du tout
le ça ne peut pas être son moment tant
que ça reste un peu celui d'emmanuel
macron il ne peut pas être celui ne peut
pas être celui alors il n'est pas
emmanuel macron qui a lui même planté un
couteau dans le dos de
sa n'est pas même c'est vrai que ça
n'est pas un personnage a soulevé la
table et pourtant
il avait un regret il a une amertume de
cette fait comme ça éjecté de matignon
quand il part dans son livre c'est
prévenance et son amertume alors après
il a beau dire non j'ai voulu passer
assez drôle d'ailleurs comment ils re
visite l'histoire met donc il a une
carte à jouer et finalement non il veut
quand même 7 cette image d' homme loyal
il va avoir besoin si un jour il veut se
s'écrire un destin présidentiel il va
avoir besoin de cette majorité quand
même et donc il ne peut pas gérer il a
déjà
lâché abandonné trahi on a pris ça comme
on veut la droite républicaine les
élèves il ne peut pas refaire le même
coup et même si c'était c'était pas du
tout la même violence que macron
vis-à-vis des hollandais est en tout cas
il ne peut pas refaire la même chose
avec la majorité présidentielle actuelle
donc il a besoin et c'est là où c'est
intéressant et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les deux ont besoin
l'un de l'autre
emmanuel macron a évidemment besoin de
qui ait pas trop de friture sur la ligne
parce que quand même ça va commencer à
agacer toujours mais mes edouard
philippe qu'il a besoin qu'une fois
emmanuel macron sera réélu sachant qu'un
jour l'un dès le le porter il y aura
d'autres cas les un dernier mot sur
edouard philippe jamesse que emmanuel
macron au contraire quoi devrait pas
jouer la carte edouard philippe dans
cette campagne présidentielle à partir
au moment où il sera officiellement
candidat mais sans doute qui aura un
moment ou un autre
une temporalité ou affichés ensemble
parce que le bilan est le même mais moi
je crois que ce qui se joue c'est la
majorité des buts prochaines élections
législatives c'est que à partir du jour
où emmanuel macron sera u syrie s'il est
réélu il s'exclut d'une certaine manière
du jeu politique parce qu'il ne pourra
pas se représenter en 2027 et donc c'est
le combat pour la présidentielle qui va
commencer et donc on voit bien que cette
majorité plurielle maison commune avec
un certain nombre de parties elle va
avoir les qualités de ses défauts
qualité parce qu'elle est large et qu'on
le voit dans le sondage c'est le chiffre
que j'avais qui m'ont marqué tout à
l'heure le fait que ce bilan plaît à la
gauche à la droite aux écolos donc c'est
une qualité mais défaut parce qu'
edouard philippe il doit se présenter
comme le barycentre pour reprendre
l'expression de valérie pécresse de
cette prochaine majorité présidentielle
qui forcément sera un petit peu plus
adroite puisqu'il prétend s'il le
prétend en être le chef et donc je crois
que ce qui se joue en réalité c'est déjà
le la prochaine législature on parle
d'ailleurs d'une éventuelle cohabitation
qui pourrait y avoir parce que la
majorité serait éclaté je pense que
c'est plutôt ça qui se joue en tout cas
quand on a gouverné deux ans deux ans et
demi avec le président de la république
je ne vois pas comment on peut alors y
ait des exemples dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui venir incarner une rupture
franche et nette
juste berne et vaud l'ain ce qui est
très intéressant dans l'étude de doxa
c'est que pour l'instant emmanuel macron
garde complètement le contrôle de ce
socle d'électeurs et les ruelles et là
pour le coup edouard philippe sa
popularité ne lui sert à rien si la
popularité n'est pas ne fait pas
l'élection donc c'est très important et
c'est là où la vraie vraiment intense il
entre un intérêt à faire très attention
on va parler de d'anne hidalgo et de
françois hollande tout de suite mais je
me tourne vers vers vous benjamin grange
peut-être un ou des des petits candidats
et forcément on doit mettre anne hidalgo
dans les petits candidats vu sa place
dans l'est dans les sondages est ce
qu'on parle d' anne hidalgo dans les
médias sociaux
alors on parle assez peu en fait dany
d'algoé quand on en parle on en parle
pas bien c'est d'ailleurs assez
incroyable parce que sur les candidats
de gauche chacun peut y installer une
politique mais il est il est très
surprenant de voir que anne hidalgo en
fait ce elle a réussi en fait à
transformer le mécontentement qui est au
niveau
je dirais de paris en un mouvement on a
mécontentement plutôt nationale quand on
parle d'elle alors pour répondre en fait
à votre votre question oui il se trouve
que on parle on parle pas mal des petits
candidats et notamment de ceux qui dans
le dernier mois
se sont opposés au passage si mal on
était quand même dans une période où on
a reparlé locaux vides et donc forcément
ce qu'ils soient opposés on parle
defilippo des nathalie arthaud d ascq
lino des dupont aignan et c'est
forcément
ça a fait parler d'eux sur les réseaux
sociaux bon quand même dans une dans une
mesure extrêmement faible on est sur des
proportions ou c'est 100 fois moins que
les grands et le volume de conversation
sur eux sur emmanuel magne et puis on a
certains qui ont réussi à tirer leur
épingle du jeu
pourrait donner j'ai pas un bon point
mais en tout cas à une petite côte de
bien jouer à fabien roussel avait que sa
petite phrase un bond à une bonne viande
un bon fromage c'est la gastronomie
française c'est vrai que sortie de son
contexte personne ne peut s'opposer à
cette phrase remise dans son contexte ça
veut dire tout à fait tout à fait autre
chose et puis jean lassalle qui a fait
beaucoup pour parler de lui sur sur les
clubs échangistes pendant deux colis de
au parlement ou en accusant évidemment
zemmour d'une contrefaçon de son logo
donc ça ça fait partie des choses qui
voilà qui sont les morceaux choisis des
morceaux choisis du comment dire du
dernier mois mais qui ont réussi à faire
parler avec ses bons mots les différents
candidats alors on va parler donc comme
promis merci ma jamin de de cette petite
phrase de françois hollande il est
devant des lycéens reportage diffusé sur
france 3 extraits
je suis pas candidat tu as remarqué
mais comme ça va pas bien c'est vrai que
choisir presque une cagnotte chose de
plus serait utile je ne sais pas je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs j'ai les mêmes
idées qu'avant donc je continue à les
défendre et est un ancien président peut
très bien refaire de la politique et
c'est arrivé être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
est ce que vous allez prenez une
décision bientôt si le monde entier
repose la question
prendre la parole bientôt
alors on revient sur cette séquence de
suite avec jonathan du prix yeahs
bienvenue jonathan c'est le moment de
rentrer venez venez la
1re soir la gauche qui est déjà
éparpillés alors je vais dire ça son
puzzle pour regarder garder une
référence une référence
cinématographique la même il a aimé big
ambigu là françois hollande sur un
éventuel route alors il est un peu
ambigu et puis surtout ce qui est
d'autant plus ambigu c'est ce qui va
bientôt dire dans sa fameuse prise de
parole que va-t-il bien pouvoir dire est
ce qui va prendre ses distances avec
françois avec adi d'algos excusez moi ou
alors carrément annoncé peut-être sa
propre candidature pour la remplacer on
ne sait pas en tout cas cette dernière
hypothèse elle est assez improbable même
si son entourage n'a pas vraiment
démenti en précisant juste qu'il allait
s'exprimer courant février compte-tenu
du caractère assez je le cite inquiétant
de la situation politique alors hasard
du calendrier qui n'en est peut-être pas
un atome à on aura le résultat la
primaire populaire d'ici là en tout cas
au sénat on a rencontré aujourd'hui
certains hollandais des anciens hollande
est convaincu comme l'ancien ministre
aux personnes handicapées marie-arlette
carlotti qui en tout cas ne lui prêtent
aucune intention cachée écouter leurs
françois hollande quand même relâche
joué notamment pour porter une parole
forte il est entendu françois hollande
notamment parmi eux un électorat mais
aussi parmi la population toute entière
donc je suis satisfaite qui parle qui
disent des choses on a besoin d'espoir
et peut-être que il peut porter des
paroles d'espoir alors comment a réagi
le camp hidalgo alors côté hidalgo fait
mine de ne pas vraiment s'en inquiéter
on dit qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout que de
toute façon elle est la candidate
désignée du ps et puis ça changera pas
mais pour beaucoup c'est quand même une
déclaration de françois hollande qui a
été vu comme un nouveau désaveu 1 pour
la maire de paris qui vous le disais
tout à l'heure un crédité entre 2 et 4%
dans les sondages en est d'autant qu'on
sait que françois hollande c'est pas un
très proche de dany d'algos il avait
d'ailleurs mis des semaines l ai mis des
semaines d'atermoiements avant de la
soutenir publiquement en corrèze
officiellement donc anne hidalgo elle a
comparé cette sortie un trait d'humour
qui est assez habituel selon elle chez
l'ancien président et c'est un élément
de langage en tout cas que ses proches
ont repris écouter
sait très bien que notre cher ancien
président et a beaucoup d'humour donc il
faut la relativiser sur ses propos
j'irai l'enjeu maintenant c'est de
travailler sur la campagne de terrain et
donc le regrette a organisé son âge à la
commune comme il se doit pour réussir à
convaincre un maximum de français dont
voilà ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui
j'ai pas de pain d'inquiétude on
continue comme dit
hidalgo la nuque raide et puis on avance
voilà en tout cas peut-être un trait
d'humour mais pas seulement le canard
enchaîné à paraître ce mercredi
prêterait d'autres intentions à françois
hollande il pourrait être visé un mandat
de député aux prochaines législatives en
corée ce tient tient ce qui lui
assurerait en tout cas un rôle politique
évident lors de la prochaine législature
donc lui il a l'air dedans le coup
d'après mais en tout cas les sénateurs
qu'on a croisé aujourd'hui ils en sont
pas du tout l'art un certain qu'on a
croisés qui ont prévenu qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu répondre face caméra ont préféré
souffler et lever les yeux au ciel je
vous en passe plutôt que de commenter en
tout cas la séquence france 3 une source
au sénat nous a résumé la situation avec
cette petite plaisanterie je vous la
donne il nous a fait une ségolène royal
on comprend mieux pourquoi ces deux là
se sont aimés voilà merci beaucoup merci
je l'attends pour tous toutes ces
réactions des galets ségolène royal dans
toutes ses prises de paroles télévisé il
faudrait faire un zapping de tout ce
qu'elle dit depuis quelques à ccc
vraiment je ne sais plus d'une brutalité
rare en politique à dire ce qu'on veut
la campagne de nivelles go mais alors on
pourra aussi dire qu'elle n'a pas était
né à la pas été là du coup tu es
toujours quand on voit sortir françois
hollande mais également bien art 15,9
une pierre moscovici oui mais c'est
aussi sa faiblesse
dans les études d'opinion qui expliquent
ces scientifiques 'cela fait la poule
c'est
parti c'est le parti cool l'élégance
voudrais quand même avant d'essayer de
porter de soutenir et puis après on
lave linge sale après elle est vraiment
encore en train de baisser à hidalgo
réalise performance sur performance à
chaque fois on est on est étonné dans
les intentions de vote vous l'avez dit
certains confrères qui ont sorti
récemment leur intention de vote la
teste avec c'est normal d'ailleurs
christiane taubira présente puisqu'elle
a dit qu elle et qu'elle irait elle est
à 2% et dans notre baromètre politique
on cherche on cherche et sur les
vingt-quatre personnalités testées ce
mois ci elle se retrouve quasiment aux
dernières places 1 20e ex-aequo avec 13%
de code d'adhésion trois fois moins qu
edouard philippe qui est premier c'est
bien bien moins que marine le pen par
contre il est une des noeuds d'aucune de
nos de corte où elle cartonne c'est
notre code du rejet alors sur notre code
du rejet anne hidalgo elle est quasiment
sur le podium elle est à 50% projet
d'axé pas que les gens la connaissent
pas c'est qu'ils ne l'aiment pas et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai été très étonné
du choix du parti socialiste de
2,2 de la pousser parce que en réalité
toutes les enquêtes qu'on réalisait sur
son image montrait ce rejet y compris
des parisiens y compris quand elles
gagnent mais municipal et que dans nos
intentions de vote elle est en tête des
municipales mais que les juges les
parisiens nous disent on aimait beaucoup
bertrand delanoë on n'aime pas anne
hidalgo donc c'est un choix étrange et
c'est pour ça que moi je ne jette pour
une fois peut-être pas la pierre aux
politiques qui donnent le sentiment dans
son camp de ne pas la soutenir y compris
christiane taubira qui elle est numéro
un sur notre code d'adhésion auprès des
sympathisants de gauche c'est qu'à un
moment donné on peut se dire si on est
membre d'un parti politique qu'on a
envie que nos couleurs soit porter le
plus haut possible ah si on s'est trompé
de deux candidats si vraiment ça ne
prend pas est-ce que l'intérêt du ps
c'est de finir à 2 3% à une
présidentielle parce que là c'est la
mort du parti elle va cramer la caisse
bah oui oui en mai
christiane taubira qui va sauver le ps
lancé ah non mais moi je ne sais pas si
les primaires populaires
social que je sais c'est que un candidat
de gauche à un petit espace déjà très
faible quand on voit là la ventilation
des voix à gauche mais qu' un candidat
qui pourrait être un jadot par exemple
qui est plus populaire que qu'anne
hidalgo et qui porterait les couleurs
d'une majorité plurielle où les
écologistes auraient le lead ou une
christiane taubira en tout cas dans les
sondages en termes d'intentions de vote
et en terme d'image ferait un meilleur
score et le parti socialiste à mon avis
aurait intérêt à choisir cette
orientation là plutôt que d'accélérer en
voyant le mur se rapprocher parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passera si le ps ne se
fait pas rembourser ses frais de
campagne s'ils font moins de 5% ici
derrière ils doivent négocier les
législatives avec leurs alliés habituels
en disant bon ben on est un tout petit
parti derrière pourquoi pas fabien
roussel qui progresse de son âge
d'ailleurs hier sur rtl anne hidalgo a
dit rendez vous le 10 avril premier tour
de la présidentielle
donc elles doivent absolument pas d
l'union dans l'est sur le coup notre
expérience de tous les candidats qui ont
raccroché de tous sans exception a
toujours été de dire y compris la veille
du jour où ils ont accroché j'irai
jusqu'au bout je n'ai connu que ça de
lipietz à qui vous voudrez donc c'est
impossible qu'elle resterait passe ben
oui c'est ce dernier mois je voudrais
vous entendre jadhav sur la primaire
populaire si on est quand même à quatre
cent soixante sept mille inscrits
ça va quand même être un fait politique
c'est servir acteurs de cette primaire
c'est déjà un fait politique parce que
je crois que c'est plus d'électeurs
qu'il n'ya eu à europe ecologie les
verts et à la primaire des républicains
au royaume uni suite réuni mais une donc
c'est quand même un sujet sur le set
cette jeunesse qui veut réinventer les
pratiques démocratiques alors ensuite on
peut être plus ou moins d'accord avec
l'idée de faire concourir des candidats
contre leur gré mais moi ce qui me ce
qui me regarde avec une forme de
tristesse qui se passe à gauche parce
que je crois que cette gauche-là a perdu
le sens du peuple vous avez une gauche
qui n'a pas travaillé depuis dix ans qui
revient avec les mêmes solutions vous
avez une guerre d'égos et à la limite
s'il n'y avait qu'une guerre d'ego on
pourrait se rassembler et c'est gauche
là pourraient se rassembler derrière un
programme il n'y a pas de programme il
ya une ia autant de gauche qu'il n'ya de
candidats et bientôt on pourra faire une
équipe de foot moi je trouve ça assez
tragique et je le dis en tant que
qu'observateur exter je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la seule gauche de
gouvernement qui existe encore dans ce
pays elle est allée dans la majorité
j'en parlais tout à l'heure sur des
réformes qui ont été faites et donc moi
je suis assez triste de voir que que
cette gauche-là a été incapable de se
renouveler quant à françois hollande il
ne s'est pas représenté à la présidence
il a même pas défendu son bilan je
trouverais ça assez ironique qu'il
revienne dans la vème république via le
parlement je trouve ça assez triste
merci et pas de l'humour je ne pense pas
en effet phrase c'était pas le niveau
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat est ici évidemment et en duplex
merci benjamin bérengère j'appelle le
titre de votre livre sur les faces
cachées du doigt phillips et audition de
l'archipel et
jazz a retrouvé la république au cherche
midi une heure